let's go through the series stuff
firstly there will come to the parakeet
question at the end to begin with first
cab off the rank we're having a look at
a GP they do tell you that this GP has a
limiting some there you go right there
so unlike in other questions where I've
said to you if you're going to quote
this it's important that you qualify
that statement like why it is this
formula sorry why is this formula
relevant well it's only relevant in this
case here right if that is not if that
ratio doesn't lie between if the
absolute value of that ratio isn't less
than one then you can't use the limit
exam formula however they've gone ahead
and told you there is a living some full
stop no extra information required so
that's why I leave me after that it's
just a matter of substituting and there
did I make an error yeah what I do where
is it
whatever what have I done oh of course I
have
Thanks so there we go that's better cuz
there's a living some so once you've uh
once you're substituted or you know this
here and you make your rearrangement
you're fine once you can of course
divide alright we have a look at this
guy now this does include what I was
mentioning before so to start with we
need the infinite series there so you
can see I've broken it apart in decimal
form and then I've turned that decimal
into fractions because I just think it's
easier to see the series and the ratio
in that form okay so does that look
better that's okay
no reciprocals or anything like that yes
you can see it then says hence Express
sorry I didn't give you enough space
there my bad I only realized after I
printed it and I did my own solutions
you can see this is what I'm talking
about right I use the limiting solve
formula but I say that the reason I
could do that is because the common
ratio is between these bounds okay what
I chose to do was to separate out the
limiting sub part from the 1 over 10
part which just hangs out the front and
then over here I combined them into one
fraction so 14.90 7 over 45 you do have
to say 7 over 45 by the way
what's the phrasing of the question that
tells you that no common factors so
that's a better way of saying it then
simplify and that's what they mean so
thumbs up happy times great so then we
move on to question three you can see
that little excuse me in the way that
the question has been crafted they don't
tell you what kind of a progression
you've got so the first thing I like to
say is just identify what are we dealing
with
is it an AP is it a GP you'd be
surprised how many students at the HSC
they just forget to work out what kind
of secrets they're dealing with and then
launch into the formula a formula I'm
not necessarily the correct one because
they've misidentified the series it's an
AP how did I know yeah very good 200
more indicates there's a common
difference each time she adds 200 meters
to each workout so that's what makes it
an AP how far does she swim of the tenth
day you didn't necessarily have to do it
the way that I did I came up with the
expression for the nth term and then I
just substituted N equals 10 can anyone
suggest why it's probably worth it even
though wasn't necessary to do that in
this question yeah yeah when I go
forward into this question I've seen
part two and I've seen part three so I
know the general term is actually going
to be very useful to me so I take the
extra couple of lines to work it out in
arbitrary terms so I got my two thousand
two hundred and fifty meters thumbs up
yep great then when you come over here I
gave you guys the reference sheet I
showed it anyway so you can see I've
used this form rather than the other one
even though this one will give you the
right answers if you substitute it there
why did I choose this form I've already
worked out what N equals what the F term
are for N equals ten years so I might
even use that because this is also about
the first ten days of course you'll
still get this it's just an extra line
maybe and an extra space for an error to
creep in so this is her total and having
already worked out what the formula for
the eighth term is I just substitute it
in here
and it just falls out very simply okay
so you're happy with N equals 25 thumbs
up